it's become hard to say anything
especially on social media that won't
upset someone somewhere rather a lot
there's a myriad of things people get
deeply offended by there are perceived
slights around economics nationality
social group sexual tastes and
commitments of every kind this is the
result of something extremely positive
democracy democracy makes us and this is
a lovely word gloriousness disputatious
we're no longer surf like submissive
people who just bow to Authority were
brought up to speak up for ourselves and
respect our rights the problem is that
this can on a bad day tilt over into a
settled unquestioning kind of
self-righteousness
it's an attitude that quickly assumes we
know what someone else means when they
say something about our areas of concern
and that they're deliberately trying to
cause us offence and therefore that we
must respond at once with anger and with
pride taking offense can be a gloriously
solipsistic emotion where we're always
ready to pull up the drawbridge and fire
rather than work towards achieving and
understanding of another person one
takes comfort in why one is right rather
than attempting that much more daring
and interesting exercise trying to
imagine why the other person may feel
the way they do we've forgotten the art
of civility the art of trying to work
through to an agreement the art of not
necessarily saying when you don't agree
these may be slightly old-fashioned
traits but they're virtues too
especially in a small world where we
can't all shout at the same time and we
sometimes may have to just learn to live
with disagreement rather than always
hoping to resolve it furthermore we
should bear in mind that almost all
offence is caused inadvertently but the
person who takes offence readily treats
everything as deliberate it's a fatal
misunderstanding of others intentions
then there's the issue of perspective we
live in a world of larger and smaller
offense
there are some properly big offensive
things in the world the things really to
be offended by er that Africa's in chaos
that certain countries have a proclivity
for bombing as a solution that it's so
hard to make a living especially doing
something that's tolerable sometimes
focus on micro offenses gets in the way
of seeing the big offenses we're
emerging with thousands of years of
history when only a tiny group in
society was allowed to get offended the
rest of us just had to do the plowing
very quietly so perhaps we're still just
letting off steam but on a bad day it
can look like everyone is wailing and
insulting cursing and cussing no one is
looking to empathize or find agreement
being offended is a choice it's a way of
allowing what someone says to get deep
into you and it's a way of imagining
people's motives as very negative
perhaps sometimes we should just look
the other way and not let it get to us
sometimes not getting offended should be
the truly great and prestigious choice